people of the internet retro raconteur
here i'm just a dad who loves games and
the stories
they tell welcome to the first episode
of
our new let's play series focusing on
the new ps5
exclusive title from house mark returnal
i've been a huge fan of house mark for
years man they i feel like they are such
an underrated developer
super stardust dead nation rezo gun one
of my most
played ps4 games ever and then next
machina and i just
don't feel like house mark for whatever
reason has ever gotten the recognition
that they deserve and maybe it's because
the the games they used to make were
such a niche type of game with the the
shooters that they made
but eternal they're they're completely
changing the formula yet the
gameplay that they've always been known
for
is still there now i'm only a few hours
in you guys are getting ready to watch a
twitch stream
my first time playing through so i'm
experiment
experiencing everything for the first
time i'm reading all the text
i'm making sure that i understand kind
of how this game works because i really
didn't want to read a lot about it
beforehand
instead of going in knowing everything i
just knew
a little bit i knew it was reviewing
well then obviously that was by house
mark
that was all i needed and i am having a
blast so far
waiting for the action to pick up a bit
there's definitely some action
in here but for a house mart game so far
a lot more exploration i'm getting a ton
of metroid vibes so
let me know what you guys think i'm
having a blast so far make sure to leave
a like and a comment down below
thank you all so much for watching guys
enjoy
returnal is intended to be a challenging
experience
all right let's do this man each new
cycle presents new challenges rewards
and changes to the world
adapt and persevere to progress further
when you die or close return you will
always be returned to the crash
site and all non-permanent progression
will be lost
interesting you can suspend your cycle
by using the console's rest mode
functionality
oh dude this actually reminds me the
opening of metroid prime right there
remember metroid prime when it's like
looking up and then it like
it pans down and then you get the
bomb love metroid man we need a new
metroid game
quickly quickly actually just re-release
the collection nintendo please
no i'm not going to skip what are you
talking about
oh my gosh
those are some slick looking graphics
ma'am
of course it's cut scene we'll see how
it looks once we get into in the game
it looks so cool dude i know i'm pumped
man i'm pumped
yeah and you guys let me know like i'll
probably forget about the location of my
webcam
we might have to end up moving it
because i don't i don't know like where
the hud
for this game is going to be displayed
and everything so we'll see
approach forbidden tracing signal white
shadow okay so she's not supposed to be
approaching but looks like
she's going in anyway
yo larry what's up man welcome dude
welcome
yeah i had to make sure i i checked that
out before i
before the clock struck midnight to jump
into the game
dude look at the reflections on her
helmet
i mean did she not see the approach
forbidden
i guess she just didn't didn't care
jumping in anyway
yeah the webcam is okay right now we'll
see once the hud gets
gets up in the game we might have to
move it
all right so she disregarded the message
that said don't approach
we don't really know why she's
approaching this planet even though it
said not to
and now she's crashed so
yeah dude it has gotten really good
reviews i haven't i've tried not to read
too much
because i'm such a fan of house mark i
know the gameplay is going to be
incredible anyway okay that was a little
weird see how those things above her
were kind of clipping in i actually
think that was on purpose
because i know there's like a
psychological element to this game too
helios did not is that her ship suit
status operational but my sidearm is
missing
i'm leaving comms open here we go dude
dude the atmosphere man okay locate the
white
shadow broadcast press l3 while moving
to sprint alright gotcha
okay x jumps i wonder if i'm supposed to
be like
looking around should i be inspecting
anything
okay locate the white shadow broadcast
that's what we're looking for right now
oh heck no
do you guys hear that
i don't know how well the sound comes
through let's see if it does it again
when i got near this
creepy indeed xfinity crapped up the
other day and the guy fixing it was
obsessed with it oh
eternal yeah dude like house mark's one
of those devs they've been so overlooked
for years i mean i don't know if i
should even say overlooked
but they just made games that were very
niche abandoning helios
heading towards white shadow broadcast
i kind of feel like i don't want to miss
out on any collectibles but
that's where our ship is i'm sure we're
going to be coming back there a lot
yeah metroid meets tomb raider
all right dude the music
already their music is so good in every
game they've ever released the music is
is top notch
and already the vibrations with this
controller are insane like when i heard
that little rumbling growl that i
stopped and let you guys hear
my controller like just gave up just a
light
vibration just a light
this vibration contains extensive ruins
of a xenotype civilization
ancient walls foundations and statues
hmm okay
turn game volume up a little bit let's
see here
turn it up
i feel like i feel like it's gonna get
louder so i don't want to turn it up too
much
we'll go right there for now turn it up
three notches
taught me that people jump like idiots
right right
and climb up ladders too don't forget
climbing up ladders larry
when they climb up ladders they just you
know they lose all coordination
that's not creepy at all that's not
creepy at all
this is such a departure for house mark
because
they're known for i mean their games
have very little story
in the past it's like just all gameplay
top-down shooter side-scrolling shooters
sort of like
3d shooters where it it kind of
alternates between different
perspectives
but this one man they're going for like
a full-on story here okay
all right we're still investigating the
signal source
so she doesn't have like a double jump
or anything that little booster kind of
automatically triggers whenever i jump
oh dude like i honestly like i've done
so little research on
all that this year
i don't know that i would i would add
much to the discussion really
i mean i'm pumped about the upside for
sure
okay obelite abolite
power xenotech devices triangle to pick
up oh yeah no problem football no
problem dude
i feel like it's definitely going to get
louder so that's why i don't want to
turn it up too much
but we'll see if i have to adjust it
again i will
okay what is this right here scout log
i have found a deceased astro scout here
checking identification on a helmet it's
it's her name
yo her name's celine
do you guys see it on top of the helmet
now she knows something's going on
something crazy's going on here
yeah larry agreed agreed
and also the fact that he hasn't played
in like
over over a year right
oh she's got a weapon now though okay
hold halfway down
what oh my goodness dude this
the ps5 controller if you haven't tried
one yet it is so
trippy how these triggers can alternate
it's like i'm pressing halfway down on
the trigger and it's like
i feel feedback that it's stopping
i mean we're just like 10 minutes in and
the game is already using the controller
like putting it to its full use and then
r2 to fire
i bet i'm supposed to fire this yep
did she automatically reload i think so
i don't see any ammo running out either
yes
i love games where you don't run out of
ammo dude okay
press uh the touchpad access your suit
computer use to view map
status equipment and data bank
ps5 increased your katie and destiny by
0.5
nice hey that's awesome that you got one
man
so many people that like i've heard
about so many people wanting one not
being able to get one
but yeah the controller it's it's
phenomenal
freaking phenomenal plot twist right
is she dreaming i mean who knows dude
who knows
okay so here's what our this is our map
dude
more metroid vibes right here this looks
very similar to
the map in metroid prime
also getting some dead space vibes right
okay obelisks i got to learn how to
pronounce that abolites
maybe they'll say it in game keys and
ether
integrity 66 percent
okay i guess that's health i don't know
why it would be down i don't think i've
gotten hit by anything
proficiency and then adrenaline top
right we got weapon damage protection
proficiency rate repair efficiency
alt fire cooldown we've got a space for
suit augments
for items uh an oxygen reading over here
on the left
yeah you guys can't really see all that
but over here on the left there's an
oxygen reading radiation reading
atmosphere
pressure check out the equipment right
here
data bank all right so let's read about
our
proficiency level five required over
there on the right
classification weapon database error
material still alloy carbon fiber
composite and
unknown error type long to short range
semi-auto
triangle for more info sidearm
self-defense mark viii manufactured by
astrotech a composite long-range weapon
easy to clean
maintains functionality in low
atmosphere and zero grav ammunition
drawn
from the self-charging let's go dude
self-charging energy cell avoid
excessive firing to prevent overheating
use only in self-defense and do not
transfer
to untrained personnel warning this
device has been tampered with
by unauthorized personnel detecting
unknown
error substances and or materials ooh
it's been tampered with
that's not good and then we also have
this an obelit
i'm just going to say obelit until we
hear otherwise
maybe because of crash that's why the hp
hp is low that could be you're right
a previously unknown radio radioactive
mineral with a crystalline structure and
a golden glow
after separating the material from any
unknown error
can be auto gathered by the suits
resource tank radiation signatures on
the local structures indicate that this
has been the primary energy
source for the sentient civilization
okay obelisks are
energy sources got it so it is highly
likely that the collected minerals can
be used to power dormant
xenotype machinery additional data
needed for further analysis
risk factor is low primary use is
powering devices
all right so that's what our menu looks
like guys something green over here
a little question mark undiscovered item
hold the scan
oh dude the scanning discovered a
potential resource
metroid prime vibes repairs moderate
damage to integrity silphium
all right let's pick it up there we go
football we got our uh
we got some of our health back right
there
all right i'm ready to fight some
enemies man i didn't expect that the
opening to be
such like a uh moody kind of atmospheric
open requires a key a xenotech gate
secured with a lock mechanism and the
red door whereas these
dude the doors are metroid-like as well
whoa
you guys cool
all right making sure they're not gonna
like
suck me down underneath
what if they just like pulled me
straight through the floor right there
all right
dude the sound okay here we go here we
go
okay i only have one very small weapon
right now
i don't know how i feel about this
oh no
oh are we overheating
wait what dispatched oh we did overload
hostile fauna i don't think that was
fauna
oh i guess it was fauna right i'm an
idiot dude
i wasn't a science major flora is plants
right
yeah yeah recording scout log astra
mk12 data drive containing audio
recording okay let's check out this
audio recording
can we listen to it playing back now yes
okay good
scout log
elapsed time this is her 30 minutes
since last crash
is her talking whole areas of this
forest are rearranging themselves like a
fluid
puzzle after each different do you not
remember recording this
when whenever i return
per astra protocol i will not be
recovered until i reach the broadcast
signal
if you're hearing this you are stuck
here too the heck dude
i don't remember recording that oh snap
she doesn't remember recording it
oh goodness okay
it didn't even tell me what that thing
was did it i want to see what this
yellow thing is
oh that might be the uh is that the
silphium
or the omelets okay that's the omelets
because we've got 42 of those now
all right ui design dude it really dude
i'm getting so many metroid vibes right
now from this
which i am totally down for
totally down for undiscovered item all
right hold the scan
atropian key open secured gates and
containers
yes i'll pick that up all right so
that's gonna
let me in that red door that was back
here
do we take fall damage oh i didn't even
know i had this little dash
i just pushed circle so you can do it in
the air
or you can do it on the ground right
there like that
what if they attack me this time
how creepy would that be like remember
resident evil 1 with the dog
who's resident evil one right like the
first time you pass by the window
nothing happens
then you go by later boom just when you
least expect it ah now you tell me about
the dash okay
uh press circle to dash hold for a
longer dash use dash while in midair to
perform longer jumps
while dashing you are invulnerable to
hazards and most enemy attacks
okay this right here is awesome because
this is where
you can feel the uh inspiration
from their other games because even
though it's completely different
you know set up here with a third person
shooter
i'm in control of a person right here
whereas uh their old games you were
usually piloting like a ship but circle
was like a dash move
that you could you were invulnerable
when you were using it so
interesting that they brought that over
here and we can just slide over just
like that all right let's hold the scan
this we got another new
undiscovered item silphium resin fills
one slot towards max
integrity upgrade
okay let's move on here all right i
don't think we can go through
that right now unless we can
wait could we encounter could we dash
through it
it's still got that up on my screen like
hey you need to i don't really need i
don't think i need the tutorial but hey
if you want me to
if you want me to check out the tutorial
wait where would the tutorial be
press to check menu for video tutorials
here we go your adrenaline level
okay this actually is important dashing
is useful in multiple ways in addition
to allowing you to cross long distances
when mixed with the jumps
you are also immune to damage from
hazards and most attacks while dashing
okay well i wish they hadn't shown me
going right through it but okay we
figured it out before anyway
you can also use dash to escape if a
hostile has grabbed you okay that's good
to know
now adrenaline we didn't know about this
at all yet your adrenaline level is
raised for every three hostels you
eliminate up to a maximum adrenaline
level of five
upon taking any damage however your
adrenaline level is reset
each level provides a unique effect
which stacks with each other ooh so
we've got to kind of figure out what
it's going to do
unique effect it doesn't really tell us
what exactly
i'm going to grab this over here okay so
we've got we've got two ways we can go
here
we can go this way can we go this way
too
or we can go this way i mean i think
pretty clearly this is where they want
us to go
oh that's awesome you can just slide
right through there like that all right
so that's the only thing that was over
here
and i wonder if my dash do i need to
like wait for it to reset
yep there i see where the dash resets if
you look to the right of my little green
health bar watch this
there's that little square that pops up
so yeah it doesn't take long at all to
reset
you just can't like spam it continuously
dude this trigger is insane i can't get
over it
overload yep let's view the tutorial for
overload here
when on atropos do not a weapons on
atropos do not require ammunition yes
but they can't overheat if fired
continuously after overheating your
weapon
slowly recharges itself but you can
speed up this process
or speed this process up with overload
if you pull the trigger
when the indicator is inside the marked
zone
your weapon overloads and becomes
instantly fully reloaded ah
kind of that old gears of war mechanic
you guys remember that
some items can give you additional buffs
for successful overloads
all right i'm gonna watch this tutorial
again okay it looks like they missed it
right there they didn't
so you just pull the trigger on the see
they got the x right there all right
let's see if they get it
in the middle this time right there okay
i got it
oh yeah see look at that the auto reload
oh i missed it
i kind of want to do it again just so i
can practice doing that
got it enhanced vision
whoa check that out dude we can like see
the door over there
dude i'm i'm gonna dig this game in
i am totally gonna dig this game i can
already tell you
i wish we had like a light item on our
equipment here
being able to turn on like a flashlight
would be somewhat useful that was
pressing r3 right there
does like a little quick scan of the
area
interesting
what is this purple stuff all right
let's scan it
let's take a look malignant key
opens secured gates and containers but
is infected with malignancy
malfunction probability low
all right hold the pick up oh no
malfunctions are negative effects gained
from malignant items or parasites
remove a malfunction by completing the
task on the left side of the screen
okay malfunctions here's further
information your super malfunction with
when coming in contact with malignant
entities such as containers consumables
or even certain enemy projectiles all of
these have a chance to create a
malfunction
triggering negative effects that can
only be removed by performing the task
indicated
gaining a third malfunction triggers
critical malfunction
which will destroy a random carried item
yikes so you need to take care of those
as soon as they pop up
you gonna make videos on this dude
probably so they may just be let's play
videos
but i might make some like tip videos
and stuff too as i as i learn more about
it
and figure out the game i think it'd be
fun to make some content on this for
youtube
all right so wait gaining a third
malfunction
so right now i just picked up one right
so
increase dash cooldown by 2.5 all right
i need to collect
artifacts
so wait where's an artifact
is that an artifact
can you guys help me oh dude that's kind
of creepy how they're trying to
they're reaching over
can i shoot it does that work nope
all right increased dash cooldown
oh yeah look at that it takes a lot
longer so i need to collect
artifacts before it will
that little malignant thing will wear
off
oh dude no
no no i do not like the looks of that
i do not like the looks of that oh wait
right here right here
oh see i knew man i'm like we can't
leave this
all right so that was silphium that was
not the artifact
these guys seem kind of cool right now
they're gonna attack me later in the
game though aren't they
i just know it i just know it
all right i don't think it's in here
so we probably need to move on
we're gonna have to face that giant orb
which something tells me it's not just
an orb
oh yeah if this isn't like boss area i
don't know what is dude
what do i do man
oh corpses of jeez xenotype oh geez
likely the architects of these ruins
dude this is pretty creepy
well you know it is okay wait did i just
make my way all the way around i think i
did
yeah cause there's another door over
there
i still say this is a boss area man i
still
say that is a boss area
we just haven't seen it emerge from that
sphere yet
you know it's happening it is impossible
to escape this is her again talking
they were gonna turn against us
oh i told you man they're like oh look
we're just so soft and friendly a pretty
blue light
come near come near nope
can't wait to play resident evil village
with your dad oh man
that game looks pretty good i didn't
play the last one
i actually haven't played the last two
but
i heard six wasn't that great i heard
seven was pretty good
and eight from everything i've heard so
far the demos and stuff seems like it's
gonna be
amazing
dude i'm surprised there hasn't been
like a crazy amount of action yet
but i can already see how they're laying
the seeds for the gameplay
and how it's so clearly inspired by
their
their past games oh
oh boy yo
oh dude this is not good man
oh yeah we're gonna get we're getting
wrecked by this guy
yeah we should oh
dude it was perfect because my dash was
on a even longer cooldown right there
i wonder if that's kind of like a dark
souls you're meant to die right there
because i do not think i was gonna take
out that thing oh here we go
return all here we go we're coming back
i think we're probably gonna have to
start at the ship again eternal return
trophy unlocked okay
oh she's back in the ship again
wait she's gotta crash all over again
i survived that
can you hear me i'm in my ship what
status operational and first person
control
i've already experienced this before
yeah who are you talking to mission
control
ship terminals helios has two terminals
to use the main terminal and the
challenge terminal the main terminal can
be used to view your overall statistics
and the ship logs information the
challenge terminal
i can't speak the challenge terminal can
be used to access the daily challenge
where you can compete against other
scouts once it is unlocked
okay so that's kind of like where you
compete for high scores and stuff
all right so what is this storage
oh there's different suits already
wait so what's the difference is it like
purely cosmetic
i'm like i'm liking that one right there
man can i switch to that
looks like we just did dude looks like
we just did
okay what is this over here man and this
makes me think about in metroid prime
3 corruption when you're in the in the
ship
the ship controls
okay what's this right here is this the
challenge one
yeah i do i do know that game football
yeah i've watched some people stream
that
it takes two seems like a really cool
game
okay data from last hour hostiles
eliminated seven malfunctions one
obelisk collected 160.
aries explored 11 hostels eliminated
seven okay
unidentified item in cargo bay removal
recommended
blank this is an order blank get away
from here as soon as
blank okay yeah
something very strange is going on here
guys
if that wasn't clear from from the
beginning
it is definitely clear now
i don't know if there's anything
significant there
safety precautions okay we might come
back and read all this later on the ship
the ship log okay it said i need to take
care of something on the ship probably
over here
are you a fan of that game football it
takes two
oh look at changing my suit after like
after i got out
okay that's you can enter the ship right
there all right the cycle every time you
die you're returned to the crash site
without the weapons
artifacts and resources collected in the
last cycle
dang man your databank entries are
permanent
okay i missed missed the rest of that
but all right
all right so same thing locate the white
shadow broadcast
dude
wait we do have the weapon what are you
talking about
we do have the weapon
oh you know we got to get a double jump
at some point
you know there's going to be a double
jump
that one's just making some weird sounds
dude the environment
wasn't like this before no it was not
oh geez
dude i gotta work on the timing on that
reload thing
there it is there it is
see i'm just spamming it i'm not
stopping
to get the reload down oh there's
another one down there oh he just
jumped up here on me
there we go i want to practice okay
adrenal level one enhanced overload
all right yeah we don't want to go back
that way
okay anything over here i could reach
something green down there on the right
something red
up there i don't think we can get up
there right at least not right now
oh that's new
is this water
i was trying to jump over it adrenaline
reset
wait so where is it above is it a
reflection
so if i can't go in there then how am i
supposed to get it
something weird going on there dude i'm
gonna try it one more time
because maybe i'm supposed to maybe i'm
supposed to dash across
nope and it took took down more health
okay yeah i don't i don't know what the
deal is there maybe there's an item we
get later that enables us to
make it past that all right so we got a
couple different ways we can go here
that's where we came from up there
there's a door over here
a door over there oh dude i want to go
right here man
a trophy and key okay
we need some health is what we need i
guess water is illegal right
like and it even looks like there's an
item under there
maybe it's an upgrade
maybe it's an upgrade that we get later
oh what is that
oh yeah we gotta check that out
insert key let's go
artifact potentially beneficial oh
here's the thing that could like
give us the corruption or whatever i bet
grants plus five percent weapon damage
for every 200 oblets carried maximum
bonus 20 percent
yes please all right let's see what this
one says artifacts
are items that provide beneficial
effects some passive and some requiring
specific conditions to activate
note that you can carry a maximum of 15
artifacts artifacts can be destroyed
by critical malfunctions or voluntarily
in the equipment tab
in the suit computer okay so you can
destroy them if you want to like get rid
of them i guess to make room for others
but it can also happen as a result of
one of those critical malfunctions which
we
read about earlier
all right we still need health
three hour time difference 9 45 a
good deal i'm a bit of a night owl
anyway
and i don't have work tomorrow so i was
like you know what this is a perfect
time for
i should do a launch stream for eternal
so here we are dude that looked like a
very large enemy
a tropian weapon charger
grants alt fire mode to weapons
l2 press halfway down to focus aim wait
we already knew that
oh
so this like this is me pressing halfway
down pressing
all the way down unlocks the alt fire
mode
dude that is sick such a nice use
of the dual sense man
oh that's cool
that's really cool i really do need some
help though
badly
oh yeah we're getting that overload now
where's the next one dude i know there's
another one
i know there's another one oh right
there in front of me
oh i just launched them
i just launched the big one i didn't
mean to do that but i pressed it all the
way down
let's go enhanced vision again
apex sphere instantly reach adrenaline
max okay xenotype device acquired
well it's consumable interesting
consumables are singly use
items with unique effects you can carry
multiple copies of the same consumable
access your equipment to learn more
about your collected consumables
wait that's not what i meant to do
tutorials
filled with consumables that can age
your progress you choose when to use
them but they are consumed on
use you are initially limited to only
one consumable slot but you can carry
multiple copies of the same consumable
gotcha when encountering new consumables
you always have the choice to swap out
the items
interesting okay and the alt-fire
you only look out for items and effects
that can affect the length of the
all-fire cool down
you can see the readiness of your fire
on the icon on the bottom left as well
as on the crosshair
gotcha all right yeah we still
we need health badly so
let me read i want to read what's the
point of adrenaline again
raised for every three hostiles you
eliminate to maximum adrenaline level of
five upon taking
its reset each level provides a unique
effect which stacks with each other and
so that thing i just picked up will take
me all the way to five i kind of want to
just use it
let's just use it see now we're all the
way up to max adrenaline
and so we've got five little perks down
there at the bottom
but the problem is i don't know what
they all are
let's see if it tells me in the tutorial
somewhere
oh there's got there's got to be a way
that we can read like what those little
buffs
wait maybe status right here
suit augments oh there we go
they're over there on the top right so
weapon damage is a plus two percent
protection proficiency rate repair
efficiency
alt fire cooldown okay so it's like a
little gun
a shield a star a little gun
a shield is that the same things right
there
one that looks like an arrow pointing up
let's see let's see if that matches
no i think they're different
all right so let's see where can we find
that's my artifact plus five percent
weapon damage for every 200 obelisks
and only have 61 oblates so it's not
going to really matter
i'm only at 31 health right now that's
not good i need to get that up
okay maybe where i i did i should have
done it like naturally
so i could see each one as i go
librarian uh sort of yeah i work at a
library i'm more on like the tech side
so i do like
computer tech help and classes stuff
like that
but i do i do some things with with
books occasionally as well but
mostly i'm like a tech
tech person
undiscovered item
ether a permanent resource that
interacts with other timelines and
cleanses
malignancy okay that's cool
can also use your ether to cleanse
malignant
oh this one is kept on death
very interesting let's go back to tutor
okay so there's not anything about ether
in the
tutorials all right
oh man i was thinking it might
i was thinking the fully charged one
might break through all this
oh it's not my timer hasn't ran out yet
hmm all right so looks like we can't get
back there
at least i don't see a way to destroy
this maybe we need a more powerful
weapon
all right so this is a this is a fairly
large room right here
and looks like we have two exits what is
that up there that little circle thing
container uh open or lock okay it's
already been open it's telling me that
i opened that one all right so the
little ones that oh and i missed
something back here look at that
so the ones that are kind of like
triangles are side paths
it seems and then these right here
are the main path dude thank you so much
for including that in the game some
people probably won't like that
i absolutely love that because you know
it drives me crazy in games
when i get to a point and there's like a
fork in the road
and you don't know which one is the side
path and you don't know which one's the
main path
what is going on here man
malignant container
a container for presumably valuable
items but it is infected with
malignancy malfunction probability
moderate needs three
ether to cleanse okay pretty sure we
only have one ether
that one that we just picked up
malfunction probability
very high needs five ether to cleanse
this one just needs three but yeah i
definitely think i only have one
i wish there was a is there anywhere it
shows me the symbol of the
oh there it is right there so the ether
symbol is kind of like the two arrows
pointing left and right it's just like
below me
over over there in that area
down in a little bit secrets i know
right
so i love when i love that they did did
that
that they tell you which one's a main
path and which one's a side path
all right so that's a side path we need
at least two more ether to even think
about doing something there
now this to me
not creepy at all
not creepy at all dude another like
metroid inspiration like i could just
see him like holding the morph ball
right there like morph ball power up
alright so i think we're left to
you know what i could do i could go back
and try to hit that side
path i'm gonna do that i'm gonna go back
that might have been that area remember
there was that one area where i couldn't
reach
i don't know though like from the way
that map looks like there the terrain
it looks like i should be able to reach
that looks like she's getting
electrified
it does doesn't it i think it's where i
i upped that adrenaline level all the
way to max
oh no no don't die all the way please
oh thank you i was gonna be so mad
i was gonna be so mad
all right is there a way yeah this way
it's right up here isn't it
yeah this is it okay perfect oh right
over here when we were by
the water see if i checked this earlier
guys
if i had checked this earlier then i
would have known that this was a side
path and i should go over here and check
it out
oh a xenotech device it requires
something to
activate it yeah this looks like a power
up for sure right here
for accurate reconstruction of complex
entities per environment
dang you need five more ether though
so now if i if i start collecting more
ether i'm gonna be torn
on which one to use it on first
because we have that one place where
there was like three different
ch look like chests basically
hey light carrier what's up dude burning
question of the night to pokemon snap
or not to snap dude that just came out
today too didn't it
well i mean here i am you know playing
playing at midnight
so i think i gotta go with you gotta
snap
you gotta snap not to snap what are you
talking about come on
come on you thinking about streaming at
light carrier or you just uh wanting to
jump in and play yourself
okay so do we wait wait what
i don't remember this before
i need to look around and see if i can
find a
nope oh there it is man
right there
for opening a valuable item didn't
require anything let's go to weapon
upgrade
modified sidearm
oh wait hold on this is like this is a
swap though
right now i have tracker swarm this one
would be blast shell looks like i have
to swap it out though
okay so i could come back and switch if
i wanted to track or swarm let's see if
i can kind of figure out the
way this looks like tracker swarm to me
oh it's like the uh the powered up one
yo it just destroyed that statue
it just destroyed that statue
oh if it's worth getting pokemon snap i
haven't checked out any reviews
i i never played the original as a kid i
know a lot of people loved it
um but yeah if it if it sounds like
that's kind of unfortunate from what
you're saying sounds like it may not be
too well received so far dude this game
like i'm i'm very early in
obviously just started about well it's
almost been an hour now we started
playing as soon as it went live
and it is super atmospheric i'm getting
so many metroid vibes
right now how did i get over here dude
okay so yeah that's the area down there
with the three chests
but there was another spot no i never i
never played the original man i watched
so many people play it
but i never played it myself
where was that spot you guys where i was
oh man where was it
and and i tried to shoot the barrier
away
and nothing happened was it down
here somewhere i feel like with this new
weapon
we might be able to break it let's see
if we can break this guy right here
no so why doesn't destroy that statue
is what i want to know
replayed it again in college and it was
still incredible
man that's awesome when they hold up
like that
okay it's ready again i'm gonna try one
more time
no dude that statue is is stronger than
the other one apparently
but there was another spot maybe it was
in the last
in the last area
all right let's move on let's move on
our objective is this way
is this game more puzzle-centric or
accident action-centric
i mean going in man i honestly thought
it was
was more action-centric that's really
what house mark is known for
but oh let's go
weapon upgrade and completely new weapon
but so far i think that i think i'm kind
of still in like the tutorial
of the game to be honest light carrier
similar to our carbine technology
so i think that it's still trying to set
everything up for me and kind of
help me to figure out the world weapon
stats and traits
unlock new weapon traits and stats with
proficiency gain proficiency by
eliminating hostiles
we can do that we can do that each
weapon you discover has three properties
all
fire stats and traits all fire is an
alternative firing mechanism we've
experimented with that a bit
that recharges over time stats affect
the weapon's power
excuse me and other attributes that are
unique for each weapon while traits can
modify or add new behaviors to it okay
so that's the thing that i picked up
for the pistol that changed how it uh
it's
it's all fire i think many traits start
as
locked but you can unlock them with
continuous use of the weapon your
proficiency level
affects how high the stats can be on the
weapons
you find your proficiency level affects
how high the stats can be
okay gotcha so did i lose my little
pistol or can we switch
back and forth
surely there's a way to switch back and
forth right
let me go into my inventory here
equipment no like my pistol's gone
but i still have the blast shell
interesting
oh no there it is there's my pistol i
still have it
proficiency level five required
let's look at the info on this a long
range weapon of sentient make despite
the exposed and open design of the
weapon
it seems markedly resistant to damage or
jamming despite the high particulate
matter present in the atmosphere
indicating a possibility for
self-maintaining materials the weapon
has high rate of fire
enabled by the unique combination of its
mechanism
and the projectiles it uses electro or
it utilizes electromagnetic fields to
accelerate small
parsing error projectiles to high speeds
although where these come from
is unclear at the moment
additional data needed for further
analysis long to short range and full
auto so how do i switch
back if i wanted to switch back
i feel like there's probably if i just
press a button
i tried everything on the d-pad nothing
r1 maybe nope all right well maybe it'll
tell me in the tutorial at some point if
i
uh if i need to okay what's this
question mark over here
a xenotech device it requires something
to activate it
like well this is a xenotech device this
gun that i just picked up
something tells me that's not what
they're talking about but hey we're
going to try it anyway
see if we can destroy these statues
whoa it just shot over here dude i
wasn't even aiming that way
and i still don't have any health by the
way
triangle maybe triangle switch weapons
nope square
nope maybe it's just like an
upgrade and so they know you why would
you want to use the pistol when you just
picked up this thing
maybe oh new enemy
yeah we got this i'll change objectives
and investigate the energy reading in
the forest uh
aren't you worried about this alien
right here first
broken tripod
you did do you see the white shadow is
something
i should know and now out of literally
nowhere
i'm hearing it again where the sentience
involved
why don't my bullets go where i aim
i need to believe there are answers at
the signal
why don't my bullets go where i aim like
watch this
dude this thing has a lot of bullets
though
that's pretty sweet
i don't understand why
okay don't understand why i think
that's part of like the side effect of
the weapon that little swarm that goes
out
there was a weapon in um resogun for one
of the ships
nemesis that reminds me of that
okay that's where a xenotech device is
required
all right so another question mark right
there we can't really cross
that so we're gonna have to go this way
all right let's do it let's do it
come on house mark where's that music
dude
kick that music into high gear let's go
i wonder if i can put jump on l
l one
where's where's the homing capabilities
right there
oh my goodness look at this thing
oh my goodness look at these freaking
tentacles
yeah i don't like this i think we're
gonna need
oh no no no we're about to die
is there not health anywhere all right
let's take cover right here
i'm gonna charge this up
there we go oh we we took his shield
down
nice nice nice all right we took him out
i don't think we can take any more hits
man
how have we not came across any health
you guys
enhanced overload
oh man okay no no
oh my gosh i even called them out
oh jesus
yeah stay back freaking tentacles
okay that statue we can destroy
dude i just need health man please
why is there no health anywhere
oh wait right here right here right here
oh we gotta wait for it to charge back
up
broken calibrator grants a small amount
of weapon proficiency sure why not
dude why didn't it go at this thing
i don't understand
i want you to go over here i want you to
destroy this
yeah it was it was vines like this
earlier that i was trying to destroy
why does it keep like homing in on this
right here
it's interesting look i want you to
destroy this
right here
just like rebounded off of it dude
all right maybe there's something else
that we have to do to to unlock that
area
should you go to better keep watching
dude that's up to you man that's totally
up to you
i will probably post this to youtube
later and even if i don't post it to
youtube you can always
go back and watch the vod but man you
are more than welcome to hang out too
depends on what you got going on in the
morning how much rest you need
right now i'm about to die because i
can't i can't find any health
you just keep finding more enemies and
no health
other versions but i worry one day i
will re-experience these same
interactions from their perspectives
but are they truly me or just hollowed
corpses
that's a good question this may be the
face of things to come
whoa
it requires something to activate it
what man what do i need to activate it
dude the controller is going crazy
vibrating when i when i stand on this
right here
i just need help please
find a way to operate xenotech platform
oh i think this is it i think this is
the xenotech platform right here
we're trying to find a way to operate it
oh
man 20 more minutes hey
sounds good dude sounds good okay that's
definitely
health up there if i can survive this
oh i gotta get up there man gotta watch
out for those vines though
yeah take that dude
oh i wish we could destroy those vines
those spines man they're the scariest
enemy so far
all right he's just gonna hang out back
there oh creates a xenospike that
impales the closest hostel
l1 to use an r to select the target
i kind of want to i probably want to
hang on to that right
oh i need to get up there i need to get
up there
right there you see it
oh destroyed that statue
all right maybe if i go up here and then
dash oh finally man and it barely gave
me anything
it barely gave me anything we need way
more than that
all right took him out
i heard another enemy
oh yeah through the vines too
i'm not stepping into those vines no way
dude
no way oh i see more health over there
yes let's go wait was that not health
i didn't see my health move up
maybe i got hit and didn't realize it
adrenaline level four proficiency rate
plus 50
okay proficiency measures your combat
ability per cycle
you get proficiency from each hostel
that you dispatch but there are also
items that can grant you proficiency
or affect your proficiency rate i.e
how much proficiency you gain a lot of
proficiencies
how much proficiency you gain from
dispatching hostels and items
your proficiency level determines the
minimum level of weapons you can find in
the world
okay let's read that again your
proficiency level
determines the minimum level of weapons
you okay so the higher your proficiency
you're gonna find
higher quality weapons basically
if i'm reading that right that's how it
sounds to me
but honestly right now i just want some
health
please just just just give me more
health
that's all i ask all right so the ones
that have like a little uh
that kind of circle if it's if it's an
empty circle the container is apparently
opened already i opened it but if it's
a filled in circle that means that it's
locked so the only way i can really go
here
is right here i believe
what was that
oh my goodness dude
i think i i think i used the uh that
lance thing that i picked
picked up
probably gonna get harry potter lego
games one through seven nice yeah i
eventually want to do a let's play of
those
on youtube as well i'm gonna try and
play all the
harry potter games before hogwarts
legacy comes out
scan is indicating potential for suit
augmentation
oh suit augmentation
let's go
appears safe to repurpose she like takes
one look at it
appears safe yeah i mean this is
alien planet it's safe guys
this is safe we're good all right your
suit can now
use translocators to teleport say
what say what translocators are devices
that allow you to teleport within a
biome
proximity translocators have a set
destination while regular ones allow you
to select your destination
from all the other active trans locators
dude let's
go let's go
that's awesome all right man you know
what i think that is a
fantastic spot for us to stop
and end the stream uh if you're checking
this out on youtube thank you so much
for watching make sure to leave a thumbs
up
and as always guys thank you all so much
for watching
i'll talk to you again soon